the first of all thanks a lot for for
coming to listening to this talk I am
representing Yandex Yandex is a Russian
tech completes a very large Russian tech
companies like Russia Silicon Valley of
Russia it's Russian Google Amazon uber
we hear that guys it's so Spotify and
everything else so it's a very large
Russian company I work at Yandex and I
am the lead of the team that is building
CAD boost library and that is exactly
the library that I want to talk to you
about so can boost this gradient
boosting we open sourced this library
last July so it's more than half a year
in open source already and we have
already more than two hundred thousand
two thousand five hundred stars which
makes me really proud we have thousands
of users that are monthly downloading
the library so what exactly this library
is solving it's great in boosting by the
way who who knows extra boost awesome
who have you know scab boost but most of
you don't know so you are my target
auditory stock is well will be
interesting for you so well what is what
is great in boosted gradient boosting is
a kind is a type of machine learning
algorithms that work well for
heterogeneous data there is homogeneous
data like images sound text or video and
for those kind of data usually neural
networks are the best solution state of
the art there is and there is also
heterogeneous data it's like for example
you are predicting credits going you
have different data oh he's your credit
history of the person his age his gender
his salary or all of that and this
doesn't have this much internal
structure in the data and fault for this
type of a gradient boosting usually
gives the best solution for that reason
in industry and also on goggle
competitions on this type of data
usually best solutions are based on
gradient boosting the next thing is that
is it is very easy to use you do not
have to be an expert like with neural
networks to build
architecture you just have your data set
you give it to the model and it just
works and the next thing it works well
even if you have a very small amount of
data for this set of reasons it is
heavily used in many places it can be
used in finance as I told for example to
predict credit scoring it can be used
for recommendation systems to predict if
the person will like the song or not and
in many other places we use gradient
boosting Atlantic's heavily in many many
projects so it's a production production
radius solution now about neural
networks as I told you they worked
really well for homogeneous data and it
is a good idea to use neural networks
together with gradient boosting and what
we do or we calculate neural features
for example for a search of images we
calculate normal neural features based
on the images we combine those neural
features with our knowledge about the
objects that we have and then on top of
that we use gradient boosted model and
we do it in many places so now how
gradient boosting works what you need to
know it is an iterative algorithm it is
usually based on decision twists so if
you first built one decision tree then
after that you built another decision
tree to make the error less to make the
better model than the first one then you
do it for hundreds thousands or tens of
thousands time of times and then we have
a very complicated there very model that
can find complicated things in your data
so that is the gradient boosting know
about CAD boost here in this slide is
the main motivation why you why you
should try the library and that is the
comparison in terms of quality with
other gradient boosting libraries that
are openly available there is there are
the libraries that is can boost light
geometry boost and h2o and there is a
set of publicly available datasets that
is from calcio competitions kdd
competition and well-known
data set adult and the comparison in our
boss what you can see is that CAD boost
usually wins in all the times rules
sometimes
she's like very very big on almost 20%
in quality increase in other cases it
might be different difference might be
small but it still wins so it is the
main the main reason to use all the
benchmarks are together with the code
are on the github so you can reproduce
the results this is the comparison after
parameter tuning so when you have
selected best parameters for each model
actually and it is also it half you can
see the comparison with default
parameters and CAD boost with default
parameters beats all other algorithms
with tune parameters in the case in all
cases except one I don't remember which
one
well--why GBM slightly outperforms I am
slightly outperforms the default cut
person that is because CAD boost is very
stable two parameter change so it has
very good quality from the start if you
do even if you do not turn the
parameters now I will dip in into the
details of the library first thing is
the kind of trees we are using we are
using symmetric trees all the libraries
use different trees for boosting why GBM
builds trees in a greedy first node by
node this way you can get a very deep
not symmetric tree extra boost build
trees layer by layer and then prove them
that means you cannot get very deep so
you but you have not deep not symmetric
tree what we are doing we are always
using full binary trees that are
symmetric here on the slides you can see
it's not you can see in example it's not
a mistake number you would have four
nodes that are the same this type of
trees it is more simple predictors that
means the algorithm
let's go into overfitting and it also
helps them to be more reliable to
parameter changes and one more thing
that you have is with this twist you can
build a very very fast predictor the
next thing is the way of the data that
we are working with there is several
types of data there is numerical data is
released clear how you work with
mark of the in DC with in decision trees
with numerical data you just put the
split with numerical data like hi it is
more than 170 centimeters and if it is
yes then you go one way
it's very simple to work with numerical
data but there is also other types of
data that is called categorical data a
categorical feature is a feature that is
having a discrete set of values that are
not necessarily comparable with each
other by less or by less or greater and
these features can these features can
have various like occupation for example
they can also have a large amount of
well as for example if it is user ID and
it is not clear how to work with this
type of data the existing libraries
either do not work with categorical
features at all like X Jews or work with
them in a not optimal way like for
example you do one photon coding you
have your numerical decide and you give
it to the algorithm so we actually kept
with this from categorical boosting
because we work with categorical
features we do it the whole set of
things with categorical features to make
it work good the first and the most
important thing in terms of quality is
the statistics based way about him so
let's say we have a categorical picture
what we are doing we are calculating
numerical features based on this
categorical features so the first the
first American feature that and that is
actually just the number of appearances
of categories you have the data set here
in example you have here four objects
with you you have a categorical feature
occupation for objects with value s de
so then you numerical feature values
vary for these three objects will be
four because there are four appearances
of the of this feature we so it is just
Quincy of the object that is the first
thing we do some normalization there but
the census is this one it would not work
alone the next thing that we are doing
is based not only on category but also
movable so the simplest thing you could
imagine is let's calculate our new
numerical picture as for binary
classifications will be an estimation of
probability of having success given that
you have this for for example on this
data set you have three as the East
the average label value will be 3/4 so 3
times 1 and 4 and your new feature
probably will be 3/4 but it doesn't work
so we don't do that why he doesn't work
because it leads to overfitting simple
example of that would be let's say you
have a single object with this category
then all right you have your new
numerical feature value that is equal to
the label of this object and you will
not have this magical feature that is
equal to the label value so it will not
work one way to overcome this problem is
the pollak you divide your dataset into
two parts and on the first part you
calculate the statistics this averages
and on the second party train this works
this doesn't little fishing about the
problem here is that now you use only a
half of your dataset for training and
that is so what we are doing we're doing
the polling for each object we calculate
those ever just differently for it for
the object number we use the objects
that are before in given one to
calculate this averages so you never use
the label of these objects when you're
calculating statistic on on this object
so for this object
so actually what you need to do that
there might be a problem that you have
some order in your dataset for example
you have all the zeros first and then
all the ones so you need to do a random
permutation to not have this problem you
also need to have some priors so let's
say when you have zero by zero for this
object so we use some priors here and
for different features you need to
select different priors to make better
policy so inside the oven we enumerated
through different priors that is
basically the thing that we are doing
with categorical features so you can say
we can do just during processing
I do remember mutation calculate those
statistics and those are my new feature
rows that but if you are writing your
own gradient boosting library you can do
better first things that you can do you
can use several permutations you cannot
use if you promote your data sets
outweigh one features then permuted one
more time calculates one more feature
that will lead to in the same way that
you have when you are averaging through
the whole through your whole data set so
it doesn't work but we want to have we
want to use several permutations so what
we do is we are training several modules
simultaneously
so how gradient boosting works you built
one tree then we got next three and so
on when people are building each tree
you first build the tree structure and
then you are calculating leaf values so
now we will when we will be calculating
the tree structure we will be using
several permutations so we actually use
for permutations on each iteration we
first drop a coin then we select using
this point we select one off for prep of
our for permutations using this
presentation we select the tree
structure then we are saying this
structure our form almost on with four
rotations all of them will have this
tree structure and for each model we
separately calculate little leaf
feathers that is basically the way that
we are able to do several politicians
and it is improvement and quality the
next thing that you can do is you can
use let's say you have two features
color and animal then your new
categorical feature that this
combination of two of them will be look
at blue dog red cats red dog so and in
many cases these combinations are
meaningful but you can but the problem
here is that when the number of
categorical feature in your dataset
grows the number of possible
combinations grows exponentially so you
not only cannot do it during processing
you just cannot enumerate through all
the possible combinations so what we are
doing we are a memory we are selecting
the combinations in some greedy fashion
so we only look on some good
combinations the way we are doing that
is the forward we when we are selecting
tree structure first we need to select
the first note here we are only trying
single categorical features then when we
are selecting the second note we are
trying the categorical the combinations
of categorical features which include
the first one and we we trying to add
all possible categorical features to the
first one and so on so we do it in a
greedy fashion
this way you are able to to have a
categorical feature combinations and the
next thing that we are doing is also we
do it inside the algorithm one what
encoding works well if you have little
amount of different categories for
example for I don't know for example for
gender categories and in this case what
I want you to not do please do not do
one important coding as preference I
think if you are using the algorithm
because the training group
the longer the algorithm will think that
those are different features and for
each of them it will calculate the
statistics and one algorithm knows it is
one feature then it can do it in very
fast so it is better to not do one for
encoding by with your hands let the
algorithm do it for you that is the big
stuff about categorical features and the
next thing the next thing is the
difference in the algorithm that we are
using so basically there is a classical
boosting where you have when you are
calculating flip values you are
averaging your new leaf value is the
average of all the gradients in this
leaf or in mutant stuff never mind
but all these algorithms they are prone
to overfitting the reason for that is
that this average gradient is the
estimate for the gradient for all
possible objects that are in the leaf
and this estimate is biased because you
are making the estimate for the objects
using the same model that the model that
was built using the same object it is
easier to see if you look on the error
if you estimate the error in the leaf
and you are using the same model the
error will be less so the gradient
estimates are also biased and that is
the reason for overfitting so we want to
not over fit how we are doing this it is
it is hard to draw on the slide so I'll
try to tell you more with the words what
we are doing is we do the gradient
estimate for each object separately so
for each object remember we have these
permutations so for each object we will
be using the gradient estimate we will
be using a model that is trained based
only on the object before given one in
the permutation so for each object we
will be training a separate model and
this way when you are estimating the
gradient for this object you have never
looked on the label of this object the
estimate is unbiased the problem here is
that this leads to an algorithm that is
quadratic per iteration so per iteration
it Indians have quadratic memory and
quadratic time and you cannot really do
that so we do
we have some relaxation of the schema
instead of training and different models
we train logarithm of and models the
first model is based on the first object
the second one first to object the next
on first for object eight and so on so
there is in the end there is logarithm
amount of different models you can you
can multiply this by number of
permutations that we have so between
many different models simultaneously
this technique this type of boosting it
really helps to overcome overfitting for
the datasets where you where this
problem stems very much and that is for
smaller datasets so for data sets where
you have less than 100 thousands of
samples with something like that you
this thing helps a lot to improve
quality but this is computationally
expensive so now those were two main
things in quality that we have now let
me give you some benchmarks there there
are three things I want to talk to you
about that is the speed of CPU training
speed of GPU training and speed of
prediction the first one is speed of CPU
training when we have put algorithm in
open source in July we were really slow
but we are constantly working on on
speed ups so we have made a speed-up for
several times so it's now really good on
large data set it will be around for
large data set it will be around four
times faster than XJ both yes four times
faster than extra boost and more or less
the same with why GBM for small data set
it will be more or less the same that
extra boost and it will be about two
times slower than why GBM there also
might be so we do not yet support sparse
data so if you have a sparse data set
then your training will be slower but
again we are constantly working on
improving the library so it will be
faster now it's already faster than
interposed
ok the next thing is our GPU our GPU
training what I want to tell you about
GPU the main thing it's super easy to
use you just people
at boost and you already have your GPU
there is a heat function and there is a
parameter task type you say task type is
equal to GPU and you have your GPU
training cat boost is the only library
that gives you speed ups on older GPUs
like MK for Trk 80 so if for example in
google collaboratory there is a three
free way to use GPU and you will have
your speed up now about the comparison
so it can boost GPU is GPU training is
about 20 times faster than extra boost
and is about Rita and faster than ygm so
we have a very very efficient
implementation so here are the
benchmarks I hope you have enough time
to look on that yeah so let's go to the
point where you need to understand when
do you want to use GPU training so the
more data you have the more speed up you
get with GPUs all right here you can see
there is a data sample counting the data
set all right here's the blind one the
black line and different GPUs so with
cables you get up to 4 times speed up
and with newer GPUs you get a get up to
40 times speed up
so you really have large speed ups with
GPUs actually CAD with support also
several GPUs if you do have them
training between several GPUs and it
will be even faster and it is also the
first library to support multi server
GPU training training ok
that is about GPU now about prediction
as I told you
Cadmus has this symmetric trees which
you can be implemented very efficient
for
thirty to sixty times faster than other
libraries and that is because we really
need in Yandex we really need pasta
player because we have other things like
ads in search so if you have a time
critical application you you can fry
this okay the next thing is I wanted to
talk to you about is the ways to explore
your model so we already can train the
model we know the benchmarks about the
model
now let's discuss what are the things
that we have inside the library to
understand what you have what is in your
model the first thing is very simple
importance and that is a nature thing to
understand for each feature you have
your future importance it's a very cheap
operation you have it like you trained
your mobile button and then you just get
the field where you have this values are
already written so it's free it's free
in terms of time and the next thing is
feature interaction and that is that
tells you about the peers of features
which features the next thing is called
object feature importance in this one is
more computationally expensive and this
one is if I want to understand for my
given object for this object which
features are the most important and here
we implemented the sharpness and you can
you can plot a lot of stuff using SAP
library very much I think they had also
at some point you have your the value of
the form on your object and you the
value of your formula is some of
importances of different features you
have some base value and then and that
is your prior knowledge on what would be
the form of a value if you don't know
anything about your future values
and then when you were when you are
understanding the values of your
features then you step out to the right
or to the left to some amount so for
example you step to the right and then
you make so you can really understand
something about how how features are
influenced influencing these objects
here it is another plot of the same
thing and that is to understand how your
feature are influencing the objects in
the whole data set
you actually can calculate Fisher
importances from that it's like the for
our the first thing that I told you
about but this thing has more
theoretical guarantees and you also have
more knowledge from these plots than
from just a number how important is this
particular object so for example here
you can see that very very large
negative impact on the object and are
giving the high positive impact you can
also open that for categorical features
as you can see which means that the
order on them doesn't really matter
because those are hashes because it's
categorical figures but you can see what
is the way they influence your objects
for a small positive so you can get a
lot of insight when you are drawing
these things the next thing that we have
is called influential documents so we
for this particular per this particular
object we already know which features
are the most important now I want to
know which objects from the date
that are the most important and you can
also do that and the next thing is
called a feature evaluation so when if
you are having a production process then
you have some features and you want to
understand for new features are they
useful or not what you can do you can
train your model and see is there
improvement or not but this this can be
random so the result that you get can be
random and this feature evaluation is
that you put inside as an answer you get
the the amount of improvement that we
have and if it is statistically
significant together with the p-value if
you have a production process and you
have a whole team of engineers which are
engineering those features you really
need that so this can tell you very well
if your new feature is good or not so
now on several things first of all now I
want to tell you about several features
of the library that you can just that
are useful first one is overfitting
detector so remember that gradient
boosting is an iterative algorithm and
what on each iteration to find this mahn
we need to use overfitting detector the
next thing is a metric evaluation during
training so basically what you can do
you can calculate also other metrics and
you can you can look on their values
like the values because they are they
are written to the file you can also use
visualization we have several things
several ways to visualize different
errors so here on this plot it's upto No
or a UC or we have a lot of metrics
there it is in you Peter nope you can
zoom in zoom out all the stuff
it is also implemented as a separate
tool if you are using our or come line
and we also have supported tensor board
tons report does not have all the
functionality that can boost viewer has
because in Cadmus year for example we
are not only plotting these errors we
can we are also writing how much time is
the training was the training how much
time is left before the ends which is
very useful and we can do that because
we have you know a similar structure of
the trees on each iteration so we can
estimate that you see the best of your
best point on the test on the validation
dataset all the stuff you can also use
CAD posterior to compare different
models in tightening you put your own
book or in cut Monsieur so that is about
metrics now and we do have missing
features missing very supported some
natural think when you have like you you
want to predict if you want this if this
person will pay back the credits and you
don't know he sorry
you don't know and to do that for
categorical features the missing feature
is separate is a separate feature value
and for numerical feature the missing
feature is either a value that is either
greater than all the values in the in
the Train or less than all the values in
the Train and we guarantee that when we
are using this split selection procedure
when we are selecting the best tree
structure we guarantee that we will be
considering the split between non values
and everything else the next thing is
cross-validation we also have nice
visualization for cross validation what
you need to know about cross validation
is that you can also use our 15 detector
for cross validation and we also have
regular pass validation and stratified
cross-validation which can be useful if
you have an imbalance dataset okay and
standard deviation or you can look on
the graphs for each fold so the next
thing is stage predict and metric
evaluation on data set basically there
is a standard stage predict
functionality where you want to know the
values or the formula on each object on
each iteration so for that but but
actually we have many metrics
implemented already when you are using
stage predict usually what you want to
do you want to calculate some metric
value on this one this on this object if
you want to do that you can use a
separate so now what I wanted to talk to
you is the parameters of the algorithm
and those are in parameters that are
important for quality and the first one
and this one you need to tune always for
all gradient boosting libraries and that
is the amount of iterations if you are
or you if you are training gradient
boosting then as I told you validation
error reduces and then starts growing
you need to find this moment the
important thing is you don't need you
you need to to wait for this moment
because very often happens and people
stop - too early so you need to wait
until convergence so that is the first
thing the second thing is learning rate
and the rule is the following full all
gradient boosting libraries the less is
the learning rate the better is the
quality but at some point you are
decreasing your learning rate at some
point the process converges and the
quality stops improving but you need to
find this moment and the next parameter
is depth and we have value 6 by default
which is really good but for some data
sets you need deeper trees so what I
would suggest you to do I would suggest
you to try the value default value 6 try
value 10 for example and see if it's
improves quality values deeper trees you
don't really need to experiment with
depth 3
cept for usually six is better the next
thing is l2 regularization is very
standard parameter and with l2
regularization if you see that something
happens you're you are overfitting too
fast you can increase the value of l2
regularization and this might improve
your quality now next thing is called
begging temperature what gradient
boosting libraries usually do when they
are selecting the tree structure they
are sampling some objects they use
begging they sampling some objects from
from the Train and based on those
objects they select the tree structure
what we are doing we have this sampling
also you can you can turn it on by
default but you can turn it on by
parameter but by default we have we are
waiting this object so we assigning
weights to them and we are sampling the
weights from exponential distribution
and there is a parameter called begging
temperature that controls how much how
intensive is this sampling if it is by
default equal to one and that means we
are sampling from exponential
distribution if you set it to zero then
all the weights will be equal to one so
there is no bending at all and you can
change it then this this parameter also
can affect can have effect effect is
positive on quality and the next
parameter is called random strength and
this parameter you know so when we are
selecting that splits when you are
selecting the split what you need to do
you need to score each feature so each
feature gets a score and then with each
with maximum score will be put into the
decision tree into the street what we
are doing we are adding some randomness
here
so for each to each score we drop a coin
and add some randomness to this score
and then we are selecting the features
among the among the resulting scores
there is a lot of randomness in the
start there is a little of randomness in
the end no but the amount of randomness
you can also control using random
strands it's a multiplier with this
random noise that you are eating this
random noise also helps to deal with
overfitting now we have we have two
papers that you can read one is only
20:17 in machine learning systems
workshop and this one explains that this
one is very very technical you know week
it explains how we deal with categorical
features it explains how we are training
on GPU why we have why our GP
implementation is faster than others and
in short words it's because we are not
using Atomics and all other libraries do
it also explains how we ask for us how
we are scoring how we have calculate
model value and it also has the thing
about the order boosting search it's
also explained and the second paper is
more theoretical and it has the
theoretical explanation of why this
estimates with this gradient estimates
are biased and why this schema helps to
make them unbiased so those are two
papers you can read and now I'm ready
for questions
[Applause]
okay what rationale ah
the reason so I'm not sure what what the
initial reason actually we we started
using symmetrical trees in 2009 I think
I'm not sure what what what was the
initial reason but it somehow helps with
being robust to parameter changes and I
cannot so I cannot explain that but it
really helps and it is also important
for model prediction you because we have
we have time political applications we
really need a fast predictor and it
really helps in that so this one I can
explain the first one it's harder to
explain yeah yeah yes yes we also have
synonyms for our parameters so that if
you are using it to boost that is easier
for you to try CAD boost we have the
same synonyms for parameter names
we did not look on this actually it's a
good question okay so I am wearing a cat
boosts t-shirt so please I'm here for
for the rest of the day so you can ask
me I'm here I'm only today we ended with
a t-shirt but next day you can
[Applause]